this is the greatest day of my voice
coaching live Blake Shelton just became
a proud coaching dad to a teenage
contestant on The Voice it's amazing it
truly is and Gwen Stefani's behind her
hubby in full support I need to give you
a hug you're so cute I'm so happy he's a
great addition to my team 15 year old
Braden late took the stage for season
22's second night of blind audition and
I want to tell you everything the words
I never got to see the first time around
I think you should push your button but
Blake with some convincing from new
coach Camila Cabello was the only one to
turn his chair
true
we got tallest guys look at that
once the other coaches saw Brayden seems
they got a little jealous especially
Gwen now I have super regret for not
pressing my button but don't worry
because what's that saying married
couples use what's mine is yours
[Applause]
you're your new Mom and Dad yeah your
parents are so happy for you your new
coach parents I mean listen you got the
life that you got me too so I'm here for
you as your mom
the pair totally look like proud parents
as Braden joins Team Blake it's one of
those once in a lifetime you know
moments and they couldn't get enough
when Braden joined his real family on
stage
oh
oh my God that's so cute so cute I love
how happy your sister is I mean
literally she is I can't even handle it
oh my God this is the greatest day of my
voice coaching life
oh mom and dad jokes aside the couples
got their own family at home raising the
boys Gwen shares with ex Gavin Rossdale
Kingston Zuma and Apollo I'm just so
blessed to have them I have so much fun
they're definitely hard work but it's a
lot of fun it's been great and it's uh
it's been a lot of fun for me
to to be the one to get to expose them
to this
out in the country basically you know
yeah yeah everything's peachy keen at
home but when it comes to competing on
The Voice well they've got different
opinions I mean being on set with Blake
is just pretty fun like happy anywhere
you know what I'm saying
how do you feel the reason there's four
coaches on The Voice is because it takes
three people to go against me ah
everybody can say that about themselves
but
so I'm normally you know
mounting my defense against three people
but now she's in there and so I kind of
have to play you know right it's it's
strategic
[Music]